bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
clôture ce soir du dépôt des dossiers de
personnes sans papiers un peu plus de 50
% des demandes ont été acceptées pour
l'instant tu autorisation de mise sur le
marché du viagra délivrée par la
commission européenne et 15 pays de
l'union européenne sont concernés
importante modification de la politique
sociale chez peugeot elle concerne le
droit syndical et l'ouverture de
négociations sur les 35 heures et puis
ce soir sur france2 beaumarchais
l'insolent et film d'edouard molinaro
beaumarchais si fabrice luchini lecteurs
au théâtre de texte nietzsche ces lignes
d'eau de l'air et la fontaine fabrice
luchini est notre invité
c'était aujourd'hui la date limite du
dépôt des recours pour les personnes
sans papiers désireuse de voir
régulariser leur situation en france
récemment le premier ministre monsieur
jospin réaffirmait que le gouvernement
ne céderait pas la revendication de
régularisation générale des étrangers en
situation irrégulière sur 142 mille
dossiers déposés un peu plus de la
moitié ont été régularisés mais
plusieurs groupes collectif continue de
réclamer des papiers pour tous reportage
jérôme laurent alain duban secret ce qu
un baroud d'honneur
déboutés de la régularisation ces sans
papiers chinois qui manifestaient cet
après-midi dans les rues de paris avait
jusqu'à ce soir pour déposer un ultime
recours auprès de leur préfecture en la
cathédrale de créteil occupé depuis six
mois on manifeste en silence mais de
façon plus radicale 14 sans papiers
africains rejoint par un militant des
droits de l'homme entament leur
troisième semaine de grève de la faim au
soir de l'ultimatum posé par le
gouvernement
tous réclament leur régularisation sans
condition j'estime effectivement que
l'on maltraite ses hommes qu'il faut en
finir de les maltraiter d'une manière
digne c'est très simple de le faire on
dit souvent que la france 2 n'a pas la
capacité de régulariser autant autant
d'hommes c'est risible c'est grotesque
depuis juin 97 date à laquelle le
gouvernement lancé sa procédure de
régularisation 142 mille dossiers ont
été déposés 76 1754 sans papiers ont été
régularisés et 64 1461 une demande
rejetée sur ces refus fin juin 98 28
mille recours hiérarchique ont été
déposées au ministère de l'intérieur et
20000 recours gracieux dans les
préfectures
au 31 août 16 % de ces recours avait été
accepté et ont donné lieu à de nouvelles
régularisation au ministère de
l'intérieur on précise que les dossiers
de recours déposés au plus tard ce soir
seront examinés d'ici la fin de l'année
les sans papiers recalés sans doute
plusieurs milliers seront alors invités
à quitter le territoire
en cas de refus de leur part ils
deviendront des clandestins et
risqueront donc à la moindre
interpellation d'être arrêté et expulsé
définitivement en corse à bastia les
policiers ont placé en garde à vue
l'ancien président du conseil général de
haute-corse monsieur paul nhat hanh
conseiller général candidat de
l'alliance aux futures élections
sénatoriales il est interrogé sur des
irrégularités dans le dossier de la
construction d'un pont près de saint
florent explication agnès vahramian paul
natali le savez il serait un jour ou
l'autre
convoqué par la justice
filmée ici lors de sa précédente
campagne électorale l'ancien président
du conseil général ancien chef
d'entreprise est soupçonné d'avoir
confondu mandats politiques et intérêts
personnels en fait deux chantiers
intéresse la justice
l'élargissement de ce pont dans le nord
de l'île est le prolongement de cette
jetée d'un petit port du cap corse pour
ces travaux d'une ampleur féminité paul
natali aurait favorisé l'entreprise de
sa fille ce que l'élu récuser déjà en
mars dernier pour moi c'est de la
jalousie
c'est un problème qui effectivement ne
me touche pas parce que j'ai ma
conscience libre je sais de quoi je
parle
ce n'est pas parce que je suis un chef
d'entreprise je suis apparaît loin de là
ce soir au palais de justice de bastia
d'où il dirige l enquête
les investigations se porte sur les
conditions de l'appel d'offres des deux
chantiers incriminés depuis plusieurs
mois la demande du préfet bonnet tous
les marchés passés par le conseil
général ces dernières années sont
décortiqués la garde à vue de paul
natali intervient-elle en pleine
campagne électorale pour les élections
sénatoriales dans quinze jours
l'ancien entrepreneur qui devraient
ressortir libre du commissariat sera
alors le candidat de l'alliance
et puis cinq agriculteurs corses ont été
interpellés également en haute corse
notamment à calvi dans le cadre d'une
procédure dite incidente à l'assassinât
du préfet erignac at on précisé de
source policière
l'étape sans tête du ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur jean pierre
chevènement connaître une évolution tout
à fait positive déclaration faite par
monsieur georges sarre président délégué
du mouvement des citoyens ce matin sur
france 2 dans les 4 vérités
monsieur chevènement et je vous le
rappelle sorti jeudi dernier du commun
en conseil des ministres demain madame
elisabeth guigou ministre de la justice
présentera son projet de loi sur la
présomption d'innocence
c'est la troisième et dernière partie de
sa réforme de procédure pénale dans ce
projet il est prévu l'intervention d'un
avocat dès la première heure de garde à
vue et l'instauration d'un juge décidant
de la mise en détention provisoire ou de
sa prolongation
le projet souligne la volonté
gouvernementale de renforcer la
présomption d'innocence jusqu'à ce que
la culpabilité de l'intéressé était
établie c'est l'un des reproches majeurs
fait en effet actuellement à la justice
le témoignage qui va suivre illustre une
erreur judiciaire elle concerne le
docteur chouraqui emprisonnée pendant
deux ans et demi à la suite d'une
affaire crime
a dit guère des cliniques c'était à
marseille en 1990 reportage dominique
verdeilhan andré germain dans le cabinet
de jean chouraqui bien en évidence
il y a deux dossiers celui qui fut
instruit par le juge de marseille et
celui qui a constitué à base de coupures
de presse les journalistes dites ils ont
été le haut parleur de l'accusation
il y à un genre tout ce qu'on peut
imaginer une curiosité long contre
vérités quant à l'exercice
s'il en janvier 90 jean chouraqui
propriétaire de trois cliniques est
accusé d'être le commanditaire de
l'assassinât d'un gérant d'un autre
établissement
seules charges contre lui la
dénonciation d'un autre accusé en pâture
à des gens qui ont obligation de faire
de l'audimat de faire du papier les
journalistes avec elle un petit
terrifiante sensationnel et le magistrat
qui n'est pas très certain de son
dossier a besoin de vous livrer en
pâture pour étayer son action ça
ressemble à du lynchage décembre 94 les
jurés de la cour d'assises d'aix
acquittent jean chouraqui
l'homme a effectué deux ans et demi de
prison pour rien la justice lui vers 600
mille francs en guise d'indemnisation
par une cour d'assises est indemnisé par
par la cour de cassation j'ai trop jette
j-3 du droit tous les labels possibles
imaginables mais après il faut virer
tout ça on t'a quitté mais on est pas
quitte soutenu par le milieu médical
jean chouraqui est à nouveau à la tête
d'une clinique
parallèlement il poursuit un combat la
responsabilisation des magistrats
je dis aujourd'hui qui a une foi
professeur de fête qui a eu des
conséquences choisi fantasy et là n'ont
ni à aucune enquête les fêtes il n'y a
aucune
il n'y a aucune sanction de prise il n'y
a rien de fait à sa place certains
requip et marseille lui a décidé de
rester aujourd'hui dit-il
je suis redevenu fréquentable l'ancien
directeur de cabinet de monsieur edouard
balladur alors premier ministre de mai
93 mais 95 monsieur nicolas bazire a été
entendu comme témoin à propos du
financement de l'ex-parti républicain
monsieur bazire a contesté l'utilisation
des fonds secrets il affirmait qu'il
n'avait jamais contribué au financement
d'aucun parti politique en italie en
sicile à palerme la police vient
d'arrêter un chef qualifié d'historique
cosa nostra la mafia sicilienne cet
homme mariano tauliaut troyat est
considéré comme ayant été l'un des plus
proches de l'ex-chef de la cosa nostra
toto riina il se cachait à palerme après
avoir passé une partie de sa vie de
cavale en afrique du sud
commentaire hervé brusini la maison le
paye pas de mine
pourtant son locataire possède un compte
en banque plutôt fournie 215 millions de
francs mariano tulio troy a dit mario
était jusqu'au début des années 90 un
mafieux peu connu de la police
il était le consigliere est l'homme de
confiance de toto riina le parrain de
cosa nostra
mais voilà les deux hommes se sont
disputés et depuis l'arrestation du
grand chef en 93
tous les membres du clan de corleone
sont tombés peu à peu sous les coups de
la police
la fortune de rinne a estimé à 600
millions de francs a été placée sous
séquestre alors mario troy a est allé
exercer ses talents de gestionnaire en
afrique du sud impliquées dans plusieurs
assassinats
cela valait mieux pour lui mais l'appel
de palerme fut trop fort il y à là
clandestins depuis trente ans un homme
surnommé la bête un tueur bernardo
provenzano
il a repris le flambeau derrière rinne
et les qualités d'homme d'affaires de
mario trouillas il les apprécie
mal lui en a pris troy a été arrêté au
petit matin dans cette maison il a
imploré que la police ne tire pas une
police ravie comme l'état italien de
bientôt jugé cet homme de l'ombre qui
s'étendent chose mais beaucoup reste à
faire pour les autorités ils sont encore
une trentaine de boss mafieux en cavale
tous sont âgés de 50 à 60 ans et ils ont
une sainte horreur des palais de justice
en albanie le premier ministre monsieur
fatos nano affirme que le coup d'état a
échoué aujourd'hui cependant dans le
centre de la capitale tirana
les partisans de l'ex président monsieur
sali berisha ont de nouveau manifesté
les bâtiments de la télévision et du
parlement était repris par la police
hier commentaires laurent boucher la
manifestation était interdite mais
malgré la présence massive des forces de
sécurité elle a quand même eu lieu calme
et silencieux 3000 militants du parti
démocrate partisans de l'ex-président
berisha on marchait dans tirana
brandissant le portrait das m a dit
harry le député d'opposition assassiné
samedi dernier par des tireurs non
identifiés
c'est ce meurtre qui a mis le feu aux
poudres
deux jours d'émeutes dans une ville où
depuis le pillage des casernes année
dernière tout le monde est armé
évidemment gouvernement et opposition se
renvoient les responsabilités tentative
de coup d'état pour les uns
manifestation qui dégénère pour les
autres ces événements sont surtout la
partie visible de l'affrontement de deux
hommes que tout sépare
d'un côté l'ancien président sali
berisha really à 6 ans ce cardiologue
originaire du nord du pays devenait le
premier président communiste d'albanie
francophone apprécié à l'étranger
objet d'un véritable culte dans son pays
il a été renversé l'année dernière
pendant une révolte populaire qui aura
fait de mille morts sali berisha n'a
jamais digéré son éviction et ne
désespère pas de revenir au pouvoir
nous n'accepterons jamais un pouvoir une
dictature fasciste ou staliniens ce
matin dans ce pays le ministre de
l'intérieur a appelé à tirer sur la
foule sans sommation face à lui
photo na no premier ministre en exercice
ancien communiste aujourd'hui socialiste
originaire lui du sud du pays et lui
l'année dernière il a le soutien de la
communauté internationale
et ce soir ils semblent avoir repris en
main la situation mais là tirana le
calme est précaire
les deux chars d'assaut prière par les
insurgés sont toujours entre leurs mains
est posté devant le siège du parti de
sali berisha
aux etats-unis le président clinton et
son épouse se sont rendus comme si de
rien était à new york pour participer
une soirée démocrate destinée à
recueillir les fonds pour la prochaine
campagne littoral de 9 ans le couple
clinton s'est même offert un spectacle
comédie musicale avec le roi lion et
puis là inquiétant a tenu à saluer son
mari le rôle politique de celui ci peavy
clinton est rentré à washington où l'on
continue de spéculer sur la procédure de
destitution désormais possible selon le
choix du congrès à noter que ce matin
sur europe1 monsieur robert badinter
qualifié le procureur canet star de
modèle absolu et odieux de l'inquisiteur
pour vérifier la popularité de bill
clinton nous avons choisi de nous rendre
dans l'arkansas état dont il fut le
guillou le gouverneur et plus exactement
près de little rock afin d'y rencontrer
quelques-uns de ses proches
ils font part d'une certaine déception
reportage maryse burgot christophe
vignal
un temps de chien sur little rock le
siège du gouverneur de cette ville de
l'arkansas et sous la pluie depuis
quatre jours
comme si les ennuis du président
l'enfant du pays avait attristé toute la
ville
bill clinton fut le gouverneur de leur
état pendant 12 ans et il était plutôt
fier jusqu'à présent d'avoir envoyé un
des leurs la présidence mais comme le
dit ce proche de clinton les choses ont
aujourd'hui changé
mccurry est un démocrate il a fait toute
la campagne de clinton à little rock
pour qu'il devienne gouverneur de
l'arkansas dans les années 80 il dit
aujourd'hui que son ami l'a déçu il nous
explique qu'il est même en colère contre
lui je lui pardonnerai pas reculer l'un
de mes amis et il a été un très bon
président mais je suis en colère parce
qu'il a gâché toutes les bonnes choses
qu'il a faites en tant que président
selon lui les électeurs démocrate de
l'arkansas et des autres états sont
aujourd'hui suffisamment déçu pour
peut-être s'abstenir d'aller voter en
novembre prochain pour les élections des
membres du congrès une abstention qui
pourrait bien profiter à l'opposition
républicaine
bill clinton est un habitué de ce
restaurant où l'on sert les meilleurs
steak du coin là aussi on est déçu mais
on aime encore le président la gérante
sous nous explique qu'il est le premier
président américain issu de l'état de
l'arkansas
bien sûr dit elle je suis déçu qu'ils se
soient des crues du billy's est lui même
comme ça à cause de son attitude et de
ses mensonges
mais je suis encore fier qu'il soit de
chez nous pendant ce temps il pleut
toujours sur les tôles rock et on espère
ici que lorsque le soleil sera revenu
les affaires de clinton iront elles
aussi un peu mieux bill clinton à siéger
ici pendant plus de 12 ans l'ambitieux
gouverneur de l'arkansas reset alors
avec son épouse hilary de devenir
président des états unis
mais à l'époque déjà des rumeurs sur ses
relations extraconjugales circuler dans
les couloirs de ce bâtiment lorsqu'il
est devenu président des états unis bill
clinton a gardé ce penchant 1
contrôlable pour les femmes c'est ce
comportement irresponsable que juge
aujourd'hui ses plus proches alliés du
parti démocrate en iran manifestations
patriotiques hier soir lors du retour
des dépouilles de six diplomates et d'un
journaliste iranien tué en afghanistan
par les talibans en début du mois d'août
c'était lors de la prise de mazar i
sharif au nord de l'afghanistan les
talibans avaient longtemps nié la mort
de ce diplôme apte et puis depuis
quelques jours l'iran hamas et de
nombreuses forces militaires la
frontière avec l'afghanistan
il y aurait entre 81 et 80 mille dix
mille hommes sur place mais les
autorités de kaboul se disent prêtes à
négocier en république démocratique du
congo dans l'est du pays à goma les
forces de la rébellion aurait tué près
de 300 soldats gouvernementaux les
assaillants l'armée du président kabila
tentaient de reprendre cette ville de
goma au robert en territoires autonomes
palestiniens à jéricho c'est le choc des
images et des cultures avec
l'édification puis l'inauguration
aujourd'hui d'un casino avec machines à
sous et roulettes
toutes les monnaies sont bonnes sauf la
monnaie irakienne les promoteurs veulent
attirer les gros joueurs étrangers
malgré les interdits religieux reportage
à jéricho notre correspondant charles
enderlin
voici peut-être l'image la plus
paradoxale du proche orient
un casino en face d'un camp de réfugiés
la société autrichienne casino austria
la compagnie nationale commercial
palestinienne et des investisseurs
anonymes ont choisi cet endroit pour y
installer 2 130 machines à sous et 32
tables de roulette black jack et de
poker certains habitants de jéricho
estime d'avoir déjà gagné le gros lot
moi je suis tout cela va nous amener du
business mille habitants de jéricho vont
avoir du travail
cela va aider l'autorité palestinienne
sur un chantier palestiniens qui
n'existe même pas ici j'aurais gagné
1000 shekels l'équivalent de 1000 francs
au casino je me fais le trip mais tout
le monde n'est pas satisfait pour le
ramasser le casino du diable ou affirme
ce tract régnera la déchéance et le
stupre une honte pour les palestiniens
j'espère que cet immeuble va s'effondrer
sur ses habitants l'islam interdit la
boisson le jeu la prostitution
le patron du casino alexander tout
chèque n'est pas impressionné il
garantit une sécurité complète aux
joueurs grâce à une coordination avec la
police palestinienne et israélienne
son objectif un bénéfice annuel de 300
millions de francs provenant surtout des
pertes de joueurs venus d'israël où le
jeu est strictement interdit par la loi
oasis pourra en accueillir 1500 chaque
soir à bruxelles la commission
européenne a délivré l'autorisation de
mise sur le marché du médicament anti
impuissance viagra
les quinze pays de l'union européenne
sont concernés ce médicament qui ne sera
pas remboursé en france n'est pas la
panacée
on compte déjà beaucoup d'accidents et
d'incidents même si aux états unis près
de 4 millions d'ordonnancés de vieilles
rats ont déjà été délivrés les fans
devront attendre avant de savoir si
d'après les résultats des études en
cours
cette pilule présente un quelconque
intérêt pour l explication france oswald
est pas très riche mais coeur sa forme
sa couleur
rien n'a été laissé au hasard elle a
déjà rapporté des millions et des
millions de dollars
en découvrant cette molécule qui agit
sur les troubles de l'érection
le laboratoire le savez viagra est un
miracle financier car beaucoup peut se
sentir concerné pourtant ici à l'hôpital
de bicêtre près de paris ou des
urologues c est la molécule depuis 94
les indications de viagra sont très
précises des maladies
le diabète comme des patients qui ont
subi ou bénéficier d'une chirurgie pour
un cancer du petit bassin un cancer de
la vessie un cancer de la prostate
également des hommes qui sont handicapés
à la suite d'un accident qui ont des
problèmes de moelle épinière qui ne peut
plus servir deux membres inférieurs et
bien ils ont aussi volontiers des
problèmes d'érection pour ces patients
souffrant d'impuissance c'est un espoir
réel pour la première fois un traitement
oral peut remplacer des techniques
compliqués comme l'injection locales
souvent mal acceptée par les partenaires
plus simple viagra j'ai une heure après
la prise
le médicament que donc aussi être
prescrit aux hommes de plus de 55 ans
dans la qualité de l'érection serait
altéré mais comme tout médicament il ya
le revers de la médaille aux états unis
69 consommateurs de viagra sont morts
depuis avril dernier
en france il ya trois semaines un homme
de 65 ans a été sauvé de justesse aux
urgences de montpellier en traitement
expérimental pour une impuissance liées
à l'âge il n'avait aucun antécédent
cardiaque connue le médicament de type
viagra ou apparentés augmentent tous le
calcium dans la cellule donc on peut
imaginer que par ce phénomène chez les
patients qui ont une maladie cardiaque
connus ou méconnus
ce médicament soit à l'origine de
troubles du rythme graves voire
mortelles aujourd'hui on ne connaît pas
bien les effets secondaires de viagra
une chose est sûre elle est interdite
aux personnes souffrant d'angine de
poitrine et prenant de la trinitrine
vendu plus de 60 francs le comprimé
viagra ne sera pas remboursé par
sécurité ce médicament devra être
prescrits par un médecin pour le groupe
peugeot c'est une véritable révolution
sociale le président du groupe monsieur
jean martin folz a décidé d'apurer le
contentieux avec les syndicats en
réglant les indemnités dues aux délégués
depuis plusieurs années en raison d'
entrave au droit syndical et puis
monsieur fall ce qui selon la cfdt prend
les problèmes par le bon bout a annoncé
l'ouverture de négociations sur la
réduction du temps de travail aussi à
peugeot montbéliard le climat social et
est il aujourd'hui largement maudit
reportage sébastien vivait
yann streiff brigitte robert et philippe
ont tous les trois un point commun avec
20 à 30 ans dans ces déchets peugeot
s'est syndiqué cgt ont vu un jour ou
l'autre leur carrière bloqué victime
selon lui de discrimination c'était que
vous êtes et jeter automatiquement vous
êtes écarter les collègues de travail
voire même évident de discuter ça se
sent on est un peu comme des pestiférés
il faut pas trop parler avec la
militante cgt
parce que ça se fait pas dans les
coutumes quand une militante début le
tract il faut surtout se dépêcher de le
cacher dans son sac parce que sinon on
vient le prendre au poste de travail ça
situe à tous niveaux la destination moi
je suis l'esprit je vous dirai quand on
est sur une courbe ci dans des groupes y
lire mais suivi nîmes parfaitement plate
et droit pas d'augmentation de salaire à
double notation salaires la cgt a donc
obtenu de la direction nationale de
peugeot le dédommagement financier 269
militant cgt certains ont perdu depuis
20 ans plus de 1000 francs par mois
comparé aux salaires de leurs collègues
non syndiqués la direction de son côté
souhaité solder ce lourd contentieux
tout en réfutant le terme de
discrimination que tout ceci nous permet
de dégonfler un certain nombre
d'incompréhensions qui pouvaient
subsister et de repartir sur des bases
solides pour parler de la réussite du
temps de travail par exemple mais pas
seulement de sa de l'emploi volonté
d'apaisement donc avant d'importantes
négociations pour les salariés mais les
dirigeants cfdt réclament eux aussi des
régularisations de militants on sait
d'ores et déjà au minimum une
cinquantaine d'actifs
il nous reste à à regarder jusqu'à quel
niveau on pourra rattraper le cas de
militants déjà partie d'entre eux pris
la fin d'une époque
c'est ce qu'espère en tout cas les
syndicats mais aussi la nouvelle
direction de peugeot
soucieuse de convaincre les salariés
d'adhérer à ces projets à noter ce matin
l'annoncé par renault d'une hausse au
premier semestre 90 265 66 résultat de 1
6 milliard il ya un an à 4 4 milliards
pour ce premier semestre 98 la sncf
simplifie ses tarifs tgv à partir du 29
novembre prochain un seul prix en
première classe et deux prix en 2e
classe ces mesures représentent 100
millions de francs supplémentaires
devant kayani pour la sncf et pour que
l'entreprise s'y retrouver
faut un accroissement du trafic de 5 à 6
% en trois ans puis un rappel enfin ce
soir minuit c'est la date limite pour le
paiement du dernier tiers provisionnel
en belgique ce fut aujourd'hui une halle
ken une accalmie et après les pluies
torrentielles hier une grande partie de
la flandre restait cependant sous les
eaux dans la province de liège dans le
sud est
le niveau des inondations baissait il y
avait une légère décrue constatée par
les secours et les habitants des petits
villages
reportage matthew chai dominique merlet
chaudfontaine une petite ville réputée
pour ses eaux et qui depuis deux jours
porte bien son nom
cette station service aux premières
loges voit peu à peu la rivière regagner
son lit et les gérants à coup de balai
dans d'accélérer la décrue par les
carnages c'est déjà deux je comprends
plus rien c'est vraiment très très gros
plus ça ya peut-être de l'eau dans les
citernes la pompe sont en panne sacrés
problèmes financiers ici en deux nuits
il est tombé 170 litres d'eau au mètre
carré
d'après les spécialistes il faut trois
mois pour atteindre un tel chiffre
du coup tout le monde a été pris de
court comme les employés de cette usine
qui ont vu partir tout leur comptabilité
les dossiers fiscaux dans un an ou deux
nous nos amis du fils corps au pied qui
vous les inondations du d'ordre des
justificatifs
alors bon ben on va prendre certaines
précautions on va faire venir un
huissier venir constater malgré qu'on
sait très bien qu'on a très très peu de
chances de nous de récupérer quelque
chose mais au moins que l'on soit dans
son bon droit
le maire et le président de la région
wallonne venu réconforter leurs
concitoyens n'avait pas vu pareille
catastrophe depuis 30 ans heureusement
alors que les machines trompé certains
habitants prenez les choses du bon côté
ce soir les villages sinistrés espère
enfin une nuit sans pluie pour respirer
mais le soulagement ne sera totale qu
une fois l'arrêté de catastrophe
naturelle signé un arrêté synonyme
d'indemnisation
c'est l'une des principales questions
scientifiques de ce siècle à savoir
l'existence dans le centre de notre
galaxie d'un gigantesque trou noir qui
aspireraient toutes les étoiles passant
à sa portée
une astronome américaine d'andrea guez
de l'université de californie à los
angeles a réussi à photographier ces
étoiles aspiré par le trou noir
explication à ce phénomène dont nous
sommes éloignés de quelques 24 mille
années lumière avec stéphane guez et
claude sicard ce disque des toiles en
mouvement c'est notre galaxie la voie
lactée tel qu on pourrait observer de
l'extérieur depuis des décennies
certains astrophysiciens affirme qu'elle
cache en son coeur un énorme trou noir
comme sa voisine la galaxie d'andromède
les personnes ne l'a jamais vu et pour
cause la force d'attraction d'un trou
noir est telle qu'elle attire tous ceux
qui l'entourent y compris la lumière
pour le détecter il faut donc observer
ses effets indirects sur son
environnement
cette matière avant d'être absorbé par
le trou noir va émettre en rayonnement
caractéristiques qui peut être détectées
par le télescope maintenant
l'observation dans le centre galactique
on observe plutôt cette fois ci des
étoiles entière ici vous voyez un amas
des toiles qui entoure un objet qui est
invisible
c'est en analysant les vitesses et les
mouvements de ces étoiles que l'on
arrive à à reconstituer la présence d'un
corps invisible mais aussi massif que
plusieurs millions de masses solaires
qui serait donc le trou noir au centre
de notre galaxie
cette image du centre de notre galaxie a
été réalisée grâce au télescope keck
l'un des plus puissants du monde
en améliorant 20 fois sa résolution
l'équipe américaine du professeur guez
s'est aperçu que certains de ces astres
tourné dix fois plus vite qu'une étoile
normale
seul un gigantesque trou noir plus de 2
millions 600 mille fois plus massive que
notre soleil peut provoquer une telle
accélération
les chercheurs américains affirment eux
même l'avoir vu absorber une étoile
proche
il ne pense pas qu'un jour la terre
puisse subir ce triste sort ce ne sont
que les étoiles qui sont relativement
proches et qui passe près de lui et qui
peuvent être absorbés une étoile comme
le soleil la terre qui se trouve à 30
mai la ville lumière non crise ne sont
jamais bouffer par le trou noir
cette découverte permet de penser que
tout premiers temps de l'univers les
galaxies se sont formées autour des
trous noirs
certains affirment même que ces astres
obscures sont des portes vers d'autres
dimensions il cela reste pour l'instant
de la science fiction
voilà et puis je vais pour continuer
c'est d'y aller avec le siège aux
commandes se libére is aux éditions du
seuil cet intitulé oiseaux merveilleuse
oiseaux d'hubert reeves dans ce soir sur
france2 l'événement c'est beaumarchais
le film d'edouard molinaro titre complet
beaumarchais l'insolent pour vous mettre
en appétit
quelques extraits avant le film qui sera
diffusé donc à 20h50
pour qu'il cesse de s'en prendre aux
parlements dans mes bras homme libre
monsieur je vous défends et moi je vais
attaquer les bras d'une bagatelle
moi je dépose votre bilan au marché n'a
jamais tout à fait molière parce que sa
vie la muse beaucoup plus que si on ne
s'en doutait change pas un iota
bon c'est vrai partout sans par match
c'est ce que tu me demande de faire ce
que tu fais le boulot qu'elle vignal
je veux bien jouer la comédie
paris grégory le lieu me paraît mal
choisi mais celle du mourir partout et
vous allez mourir mais je veux marcher
est ce une habitude chez vous le quittez
les femmes après avoir obtenu d'un
squeeze vie et qu'on se paye ou pourquoi
m'arrêtez vous vous intelligence avec
l'ennemi
il m'aide à me relire cette réplique le
droit au bonheur des dames de coeur
monsieur de beaumarchés
la manche le vent ne me reste plus
qu'une arme de mes ennemis je crains
rien les mouvements occire c'est bien la
première c'est vrai ce qui n'y vont soir
vous aviez dit que vous aviez beaucoup
aimé l'entousiasme de beaumarchais
codevi tour dessine c'était il ya un oui
ça doit être ça si je les dis c'est que
ça devait être vrai c'est qu'il ya
quelque chose de faux rendre hommage à
molinaro edouard molinaro à guitry à
charles gassot parce qu'un film c'est
toujours la volonté d'un homme et cette
chaîne qui a eu le courage de se lancer
dans quelque chose qui est le contraire
de rébarbatif
parce que c'était impossible d'essayer
de traiter un caractère aussi fit aussi
romanesque bon marché enfin le la
première chose qui est incroyable revu
cet après-midi du film c'est que c'est
du plaisir ça s'alourdit pas ça veut pas
pesé en expliquant l'histoire et
pourtant l'histoire est toujours là et
c'est pas du bavardage c'est de la belle
langue
abbas et guitry 1 1 ce n'est pas le
dernier des rats quand même il ya eu un
plaisir à le dire ce cette lente selon
lui à exercer au spectateur de l'avoir
toujours les journalistes disent tous
jose c'est un plaisir de dire ses textes
mais c'est pas tellement important de
savoir si nous on a du plaisir
ce qui est important c'est surtout que
ils en prennent oui vous dit même que le
spectateur ne va pas comprendre mais
sentir mais c'est pas de moi c'est de
jouer
oui enfin vous leur dites j'essaye de me
hisser à la hauteur de cette maxime
parce que faire comprendre les choses
c'est très facile si on fait appel à
l'intellect mais faire éprouver des
sensations
c'est un métier qui s'appelle le métier
d'acteur beaumarchais c'est une leçon
politique de preuves ou pas c'est infini
la psychologie et là le parcours de cet
homme c'était impossible à réduire
c'était infaisable
la singularité du projet beaumarchais
c'est qu'on pouvait pas faire ça c'est
impossible de faire un
il était donc espions dramaturge
exceptionnel amoureux hommes de finances
musicien créateur
comment sa vie qui était par essence
supérieure à tout
si on pouvait être résumée s'en est
réductrice ans il faisait de la
politique s'occupe notamment d'aidés
pour l'indépendance des états unis
donc c'est aussi de la politique et si
je vous pose pas parce que j'ai une
deuxième question derrière c'est que
vous a priori la politique et
l'engagement politique c'est pas votre
la politique c'est de jouer à tous les
soirs et de parts et de pavot l'ailé et
de pas volé le public
mais la politique vous et regardez
journal vous suivez la grille mélodique
this way to pas s'abandonner à des
déclarations idéalisée comme ça qui
n'engagent que quelques mots pendant
quelques secondes
la politique c'est ses mythes et -pour
être un tout petit peu moins médiocre
voilà c'est militer pour quelque chose
de bien enfin je sais pas c'est pas je
sais pas ce que ça va oui sans
s'intéresser je sais pas je sais pas du
tout voilà la dimension de la politique
dont vous parlez c'est à dire
l'actualité la vie du monde les affaires
du monde des hommes comment ils sont
gérés comment ils se battent la violence
la guerre vous votre militants c'est la
langue le théâtre c'est comme vous
insistiez de m'en sortir un petit peu
dans cette affaire un peu dans laquelle
on comprend rien c'est à dire de vivre
c'est difficile déjà alors je sais pas
ce que je comprends pas bien ce que les
gens en emploi qu'homme politique je ne
sais pas trop ce que ça veut dire
hier soir je suis allez vous voir au
théâtre de la renaissance et j'ai le
sentiment qu'en lisant nietzsche
baudelaire céline lafontaine en disant
ces textes d'une certaine manière vous
étiez à la fois seul et en même temps
avec le public il y à il ya comme une
sorte de plaisir à la fois de les dire
et en même temps un eu une envie qu'il
soit écouté très fortement par le public
oui j'espère que j'espère que j'aille à
la volonté de le faire écouter n'est pas
trop forte parce que pour qu'une
représentation soit réussie
il faut que la volonté de l'acteur soit
assez assez neutraliser c'est comme une
histoire d'amour quand une femme veut
trop quand un homme veut trop quelque
chose bloque c'est intéressant une
représentation parce qu'il faut pas
vouloir trop de choses alors il faut
mais comment expliquez-vous que
nietzsche baudelaire céline voir la
fontaine ça fasse un énorme succès
populaire de théâtre car c'est un énorme
succès populaire de théâtre ce que vous
faites en ce moment comment vous
expliquez ça qu'a priori la fiche comme
dirait robert mais pourquoi vous voulez
expliqué j'ai envie de comprendre mais
pour bah on comprend pas grand chose
dans la vie donc faut cesser de vouloir
comprendre c'est impossible à comprendre
puisque c'est peut-être des mauvaises
raisons c'est peut-être des bonnes
raisons peut-être que les succès sont
des malentendus peut-être que c'est
c'est très ses 13 ans inexplicable tout
ce qui est avancé n'est pas satisfaisant
je pense que simplement les gens ils
sont faut pas non plus penser qu'ils ont
pas envie d'être de ne pas communier
avec quelque chose de vivant qui est la
langue de la fontaine par exemple cet
esprit-là cette espièglerie la delà de
vos marchés grâce au talent de guitry
notamment molinaro id tout ça cette
espièglerie là alors c'est plaisir là
qu'est ce que ça veut dire la langue
c'est certainement pas des mots bien
écrit ce pas une belle langue bien écrit
venant c'est certainement une ante un
enthousiasme de l'énergie de l'énergie
pourquoi les spectateurs sortent en
ayant l'impression de pas avoir été
écrasé sans aucune leçon didactique
pourquoi il joue avec les auteurs
pourquoi là ils ont une place entière
enfin parce que le génie de ses auteurs
c'est un génie qui va percer dans le
coeur de quelque chose d'universel et
qui sait les secrets et infini de
l'existence et ça n'a rien évidemment
c'est exactement comme le film de
beaumarchais
c'est dès qu'on en parle on va venir
c'est pour arte alors que quand les gens
nous voient les premières annonces ont
ri en plus on est enchanté
on vous retrouve vous savez qu'il faut
aux herbiers c'est à 21h merci beaucoup
de vous être déplacés ont des jeux vous
encore quelques minutes pour hbo marché
et puis je voudrais acheter son journal
avec le du football pour la coupe
d'europe parce que je sais qu'en ce
moment marseille et mener 2 1 mais vous
allez revoir quelques-uns début de
monaco lotz monaco a gagné et de mettre
sa belgrade face à l'étoile rouge mais a
perdu même pour fabien barthez difficile
de reprendre la routine
après des vacances au sommet du monde et
avouons le pour les polonais privé de
séjour parisien marqué un but au
meilleur gardien du mondial serait une
belle revanche
alors lorsqu au bout de dix minutes de
jeu barthet s'incline devant une belle
talonnade des blancs et rouges monaco
s'inquiètent
à tel point que pendant plus de trois
quarts d'heure les monégasques eux vont
s'escrimer à marquer sans jamais toucher
pour l'un des meilleurs clubs français
armé de trois champions du monde la
défaite face au modeste club de lot qui
n'a jamais franchi un tour européen
serait une grosse surprise
mais à force de dominer monaco
concrétise d'abord sur une frappe de
giuly dévié par la défense polonaise
puis à force d' attaque les hommes de
tigana poussent leurs adversaires à la
faute
un penalty transformé par david
trezeguet désormais les hommes de lot
retranchés dans leurs surfaces subissent
la furie jaune et noir côté monégasque
que tout le monde s'y met et c'est
finalement spehar qui inscrit le dernier
but
qu'est ce qu'on ne ferait pas pour faire
plaisir au patron
en revanche pour mais ça ne va pas fort
à croire que l'europe est bien trop
grande pour le petit club lorrain
éliminé de la ligue des champions par
les amateurs d'helsinki confronté à
l'étoile rouge de belgrade en uefa les
messages n'ont pas fait illusion
longtemps
deux buts encaissés dans le premier
quart d'heure de jeu pour mais c'est un
peu d'europe qui s'envole le but de
rodriguez dans les arrêts de jeu arrive
trop tard la victoire est pour belgrade
le fc metz dauphin des champions lensois
la saison passée avant dernier du
championnat
cette année voit son règne s'achever le
déclin de l'empiré lorrain a bien
commencé voilà nous sommes un peu en
retard dans quelques instants donc
beaumarchais à demain 20h bonsoir